hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here's just
some general Insanity of the day a
councilman is coming out as a
transgender best transgender and a woman
of color Delaware County Councilman Ryan
Webb announced that he now identifies as
an indian-american woman
since that announcement he's received
some support but a lot of backlash many
calling him childish despicable even
calling for things like execution in a
statement Webb gave to in teammate he
says quote it is unfortunate that I
cannot simply be given the same space
and respect to explore my identity that
so many of those targeting me demand for
themselves it's possible I may change my
mind down the road the process of
identity exploration is complex and
often times at the end of our personal
Journey we end right back where we
started Webb goes on to tell it mate
this is just his true authentic self
foreign